hello everyone I'm any Redmond and i'm
here with my co-stars Catherine Wolfson
Alison sudol and Dan foger from the new
film fantastic beasts and where to find
the story of Maja's ologist Newt
Scamander who arrives in New York and
accidentally unleashes his magical
beasts into the city it has attempts to
recover as mischievous creatures he
befriends two magical sisters at one
unsuspecting nomad that's what we call
muggles here in America together the
foursome become unlikely friends as an
unpredictable chain of events sweeps
them into a race to uncover the dark
forces threatening both the Wizarding
and Nomad worlds check out the trailer
and don't forget to follow the film on
Facebook and Twitter see you in cinemas
this November
you
you know over 24 hours that an
unregistered wizard set magical beasts
loose in New York yes where is this man
so here to go with the case full of
monsters huh
whose child is first this is Fanta do
you know anything about the Wizarding
community in America
we don't let things loose hey mister
English guy I think your egg is hatching
you wait his memory right there no
matter what no magic there not one
wizard sorry we call the muggles
I don't think I'm dreaming okay vit away
ain't got the brains to make this up
reconstruction and then disappearing
without a trace witches live among us
we've lived in the shadows for too long
a school who does this protect
yes thank you
he's answers in yet this is related to
Grindelwald attacks in the Europe
this could mean war we got a plan right
guys they need our help
what's that everything that came out of
the case
I want another one time I refuse to bow
down at all
time is running out
let's just go ahead
it's on look why would I have to wear
something like this because your skull
is susceptible to breakage under immense
force